i want to make this video
in support of ukraine this is steve
kaufman
i'm going to say a few things in english
and then i will
repeat my
message of support
in
a number of other languages hopefully i
can remember which languages i want to
speak in
uh
since the annexation of crimea i have
been following events in ukraine
largely on russian media such as
echo muskegon al dost
twitter
and ukrainian sources along the way i
have learned enough ukrainian that i can
understand what the ukrainians are
saying
uh
there's no question that ukraine has had
has lots of problems
uh tensions between different regions
between different political parties
uh different political aspirations
uh probably not not that much language
tensions despite
the attention that's paid to that
issue
and all of these problems
the ukrainians could have resolved
themselves with perhaps the odd
demonstration perhaps the odd conflict
here and there but if the ukrainians had
been left to their own devices we would
not have the humanitarian disaster that
we now have in eastern ukraine
where
3000 people have been killed
millions have left have had to leave
their homes and homes and lives have
been destroyed
the cause of this
degree of humanitarian
uh
disaster in my opinion is without a
doubt the policies of putin's russia
they have been whipping up
nationalist fervor
and this is not recent this goes back i
mean since in the years that i've been
following events in russia
this uh nationalism has been and this
anti-western
anti-us anti-european feeling has been
consistently nurtured in russia
uh
then the seizing of crimea
uh
further stoked this nationalism in
russia
and then
the sort of
diabolical
hate propaganda of the
government-controlled russian media
painting the kia government kiev
government as
fascists and uh you know dominated by
the right sector and basically creating
totally false
uh uh and unnecessary
unjustified fears in the minds of people
in in eastern ukraine
uh then
to top that all off
uh you have russian citizens like igor
gierkin
who recruits people in crimea
with the specific intention of them
taking these armed people who were part
of the events in crimea taking them to
eastern ukraine
and to make sure that whatever unrest
and unhappiness there is or
dissatisfaction there is in east ukraine
vis-a-vis give
that this then becomes as violent as
possible as quickly as possible and so
they arrive with their machine guns
uh and they're all ex-fsb operatives
and
as a result things have spiraled out of
control
and the russian government has further
uh provided arms to the rebels provided
the leadership the border girikin
others leaders
uh
arms as i say
mercenaries they have allowed
people in russia to recruit
volunteers to go and fight in ukraine
to take arms in ukraine i mean all of
these things are obviously against the
law and now recently we see regular
russian troops fighting
in fact a very decisive role by regular
russian troops in ukraine so with all of
this the ukrainians who started out six
months ago very disorganized and who are
still quite disorganized have shown
tremendous spirit in my opinion i'm very
impressed with them that's not to say
that they haven't made mistakes that
there haven't been excesses occasionally
but nowhere near on the scale of the
violation of basic human rights and the
sadistic
uh nature
of much of the activity of the
russian-sponsored
rebels in eastern ukraine so i support
ukraine i support an independent and
democratic ukraine
democratic
uh
uh
um
yo apollo
um
um
lingua
uh
is
um
foreign